is it possible to buy a property using
little to no money the answer is
absolutely yes purchase lease option
agreements it's when you buy a house now
but you agree to pay for it later now
this blows people's minds like how can
you buy a house now and pay for it later
the great thing about doing that is if
you buy a house now but you pay nothing
or okay technically you have to pay £ as
a purchase lease option fee but if you
take a house now and you pay a pound and
you have the option to pay for it in 7
years what are you going to do in the
meantime between now and 7 years you're
going to rent it out and what happens to
houses generally over time they go up
and what are you going to do with that
money you're going to put it into a
little pot and then after 7 years that
pot is going to have grown to become
what the deposit to buy the house